just like you look different in several
stages of your lifecycle chromosomes
inside the cell also look different in
different stages of the cell cycle
sometimes they're in an open chromatin
stage and this kind of appearance is
known as beads on string and this kind
of situation is seen in the interphase
stage where the chromatin is
transcriptionally active sometimes also
these chromosome could stay in a
condensed it like that
in metaphase but they are not
transcriptionally active so depending
upon the stages of the cell cycle we can
find different profiles of chromosomes
but be it in a condensed state or in a
transcriptionally relaxed state the
basic subunit or the basic structural
unit for the chromosome is called the
nucleosome which is formed of DNA and
basic protein known as histone histone
our basic protein which are rich in
lysine and arginine all the basic amino
acids now the basics unit of the
nucleosome is a histone core and DNA so
DNA wrapped around the nucleus on
basically the histone core to form the
nucleosome now there are h3 and h4
histones which form
pair with each other to form our h3 h4
timer so as h2a and h2b form h to a to b
timer now h3 h4 form a tetramer top of
which h2 a to b dimer sits on and thus
they form a core histone octamer DNA is
negatively charged due to the phosphate
backbone now negatively charged DNA is
wrapping around the core histone octamer
and there are many type of interaction
one of that is ionic interaction between
the positively charged is
- an Optima vs. the negatively charged
DNA backbone that is how the nucleosome
is stabilized now if we talk about a
little bit about structure of the
histones histone has two characteristic
structural domains one is a histone fold
histone fold is basically a collection
of three alpha helices which are
conserved across all the histones so if
we take his turn to a h3 or h4 more on
this the structural features are similar
in this histone fold region and is it is
structurally and functionally conserved
also it has a elongated n-terminal tail
which is also rich in lysine and
arginine and several other amino acid
residues and this histone tail is
hotspot for several modifications in the
histone so let's just ask that what is
the importance of these structural
domains at a functional level so the
histone tail does not help me form
condensation of the chromosome or
wrapping the DNA around it because I
experiments suggest when there is a mild
trypsin digestion of the nucleosome
which cleaves of the n-terminal tail the
nucleosome still remains in a proper
conformation that means the histone fold
is the structure which is interacting
with the DNA and stabilizing the
nucleosome not the in terminal tail
whereas the in terminal tails are site
for several modifications like
acetylation methylation etc etc so now
the question comes how the interaction
between these core histones core histone
histone folds and DNA occurs it turns
out that DNA interaction - the histone
happens in the minor groove and we know
that minor groove or phosphate backbone
they are not reach-in information so the
histone interaction with the DNA
not sequence-specific also the
interaction type is non-covalent in
nature mostly hydrogen bonds and ionic
interaction many of the cases there are
also Vander Waals interaction as well
then why is there no sequence
specificity between DNA histone
interaction now the question is if there
is a sequence specificity between
histone and DNA interaction then cell
has to produce several thousand
different type of histones in order to
recognize a specific sequence of DNA
that is why histones generally interacts
with minor groove and phosphate build
back backbones which are less reach any
information and histone tails are rich
in several type of amino acids which are
hotspot for modifications like
phosphorylation methylation as a
dilation etc now how do people know that
how much DNA is associated with the
nucleosome now we know that 200 base
pair of DNA roughly is associated with
the nuclear zone so in past scientists
did one important experiment where they
took the nucleosome I mean DNA in intact
form of nucleosome and they digested
with micro cockle nucleus as a result
they check the band's the chorus the DNA
attached with those complexes they check
the bands they always get a band roughly
for a long time digestion or a harsh
digestion they always get a band around
200 base pairs and for a mild digestion
they either get a 200 base pair band or
something which is corresponding to a
multiple of that that tells us that
nucleosome associated DNA is roughly 200
base pair in size now we talked about
several cool histones apart from core
histones there are
linker histones which is histone h1 now
linker histone interacts with each other
and help in compaction from a bead on
string structure it formed to a 30
nanometer cable solenoid structure so
the compaction is aided by this h1
linker histone and that helps in
higher-order folding and packaging of
the chromosome inside the nucleus I hope
this video was informative if you like
my videos give it a big thumbs up don't
forget to Like share and subscribe